the lie that certain people in america
are incapable
of personal decision making we're not
talking about people who have some sort
of
actual disability we are talking about
simply based on your race you are
incapable of making a decision for which
you can be held responsible
this is now implicit in so much of
left-wing talking points
the most obvious place in which this is
is implicit it's not even implicit it's
almost explicit is the way the left will
talk about voting
so right now the left's case is that any
republican attempt
to create a regiment of voter id where
we can actually verify where you are
from
or to limit in some way early voting
this is somehow racist
the idea implicit here is that somehow
this is going to directly affect black
people specifically why are black people
incapable of getting a voter id that's
ridiculous
it's ridiculous are black people
incapable of voting on the day of
elections
of course not what exactly is racist
about seeking better voter verification
standards
and so the based on this original lie
what you will see piled up
are more lies right so the original lie
is that certain people in america are
not capable of making certain decisions
which is not true
and then rooted in that lie you'll see
lies about the policies that are being
promulgated
stacey abrams of course has been a big
proponent of the idea that massive voter
suppression is happening across the
country this is simply not the case
there is not massive voter suppression
it's amazing throughout 2020 we kept
hearing
that donald trump was saying things that
were untrue about voting about voter
fraud and voter irregularity
and i said okay well he has to provide
proof of voter fraud and voter
irregularity if we are going to believe
that
the media agreed okay but then the media
would say voter suppression is
widespread it's happening across the
country there is no evidence of
widespread voter suppression in the
united states
this is not a reality black americans
over represent
their percentage of the population in a
wide variety of swing states
when it comes to voting the the notion
that georgia was being victimized by
voter suppression is a lie
the notion that voter suppression was
taking place
in 2012 or 2016 or 2020 it's not true
but the media
pushed that narrative why because the
idea was that if they didn't get their
way it must be due to america's racist
systems it's always the racist system
that is depriving certain individuals of
choice even though in a free country
people are capable of the choice so you
see stacey abrams out there suggesting
that we're seeing an onslaught on voting
in this country
thanks to for example georgia law so
georgia's new law is not
it is not an onslaught on voting in this
country
georgia's new law is actually more lacks
on early voting than say new jersey
georgia's new law does not prevent
people from voting
it does not prevent people from drinking
water in line it does not prevent people
from being able to obtain a ballot it
doesn't do any of those things
and yet the argument from the left is
that it is designed to stop black people
from voting because somehow black people
are what incapable of jumping through
the
very basic hoop of getting an id i don't
think so here's stacey abrams pushing it
anyway
we deserve to have a say in the
direction of our nation
in the direction of our states and in
the direction of our communities
and when democracy is undermined by laws
that we have seen pass
not only in georgia but in iowa and laws
that are under consideration in arizona
in texas in new hampshire in florida
in 43 states across this country we are
seeing an
onslaught an attack on democracy that is
a lie it is not an attack on democracy
it is not an
onslaught these are very simple
verification procedures
and democrats want to undermine all of
those that's what the so-called for the
people act is all about this hr one
it is all about undermining voter
verification procedures
okay so recognize the actual agenda
which is to loosen voting procedures so
that
fraud actually becomes more common and
the possibility of fraud becomes more
common and ballot harvesting which i
think is one of the most nefarious
things in american voting
becomes the rule of the land that's the
actual goal but but in order to push
that goal they're going to continue to
foster the lie
that these measures are aimed at
stopping black people from voting and or
black people are incapable of voting if
you put these conditions in place that
are equally applicable to everyone
how stupid are these lies they're so
stupid that even the washington post
which is a left-wing outlet
is now fact-checking these lies joe
biden suggested that the new georgia law
quote ends voting hours early
that it suppresses voting he got four
pinocchios for this because it's not
true
okay on election day in georgia polling
places are open from 7 a.m to 7 p.m
if you're in line by 7 pm you're allowed
to cast your ballot nothing in the new
law changes those rules that didn't stop
joe biden from going out there and
saying that this
initiative is called un-american and
sick
he said quote deciding that you're going
to end voting at five o'clock when
working people are just
getting off work among the outrageous
parts of this new state law it ends
voting hours early
okay none of this is true it is not true
university of georgia political sciences
charles bullock says you can criticize
the bill for many things i don't think
you can criticize it for reducing the
hours you can vote
so he's just telling things that are
openly untrue at this point
the washington post tries to make
excuses for biden
but it's a lie anyway and there's an
overall lie
okay the overall lie again is that these
voting verification laws are designed to
prevent black people from voting it is
not or that black people are incapable
of fulfilling these particular promises
this is not the case
but again this is the line how prevalent
are these lies about georgia's voting
laws for example they're so prevalent
that jamel hill who somehow continues to
fail up she started off at espn lost her
job at espn
now she's over at the atlantic which is
supposed to be some sort of highfalutin
intellectual magazine which of course it
is not
she has a piece titled sports should
boycott georgia
so now because she doesn't like the law
in georgia
because it is supposedly racist this
means
that now all sports should boycott
georgia
right the politicization of everything
along along the basis of these lies
is pretty astonishing it truly is
and the the attempt to craft all of
american life around the lie
that laws that are equal in
applicability and do not victimize black
americans actively victimize black
americans because somehow black
americans are incapable of making basic
decisions
that lie is now being embedded in every
area of american life
it's being embedded in corporate life
it's being embedded in sports it's being
embedded in government it's being
embedded
in hollywood it's all embedded people
are not responsible for their own
decisions because america is such a
terrible racist place
so jamel hills says that she now wants
sports organizations to boycott the
state of georgia she says in the past
major sports organizations have forced
other states to reconsider infringements
on their citizens rights
and that kind of pressure is sorely
needed in georgia now last week
georgia's republican governor brian kemp
signed an elections bill
joe biden has described as jim crow in
the 21st century which shows you what an
insane lie that is
jim crow explicitly created a separate
system of law for black americans and
treated them as inferior
there's nothing in the law like that
that is that's not only an overstatement
it's just an outright lie
but says jamelle hill all of corporate
america should resonate to the lie
the law imposes new voter identification
requirements for absentee ballots well
clearly that's racist
i mean you mean you have to show that
you are who you say you are when you
vote absentee
if you can explain to me how that's
racist i'm willing to hear it
anyone bueller bueller it limits the use
of ballot drop boxes
oh you mean like ballot drop boxes where
people could just stuff the ballot box
or take ballots out of the ballot box
hmm it hands state officials more power
over local elections
even before the legislation passed many
voters of color in georgia faced
hours-long queues at the polls by the
way
voter suppression doesn't involve long
lines
any more than long lines at disneyland
are ride suppression
you know what voter suppression is voter
suppression is where you don't get to
vote
making those weights even more arduous
the new law bans giving food and water
to people in line of vote that's not
even true it banned giving any gift to
people in line when they are within 150
feet of the polling place you can bring
water with you there are people outside
who can give you water this is just not
true
okay so so again the the root lie here
is the one that is being pushed forward
that's being pushed forward in every
area of american life people are not
responsible for their own actions
whether we are talking criminal behavior
or whether we are talking about voting
law people are not responsible for their
own behavior so long
as we can continue to forward the
narrative that america is deeply racist
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show
if you did go ahead and hit the
subscribe button so you stay up to date
on all of our future content